on your mark get set that's Kate
Middleton showing off her sporty side at
the London Stadium on Wednesday where
she participated in a special sports 8
event the Duchess of Cambridge has been
a patron of the organization since 2013
which helps young British athletes
aspiring to be the country's next
Olympic Paralympic Commonwealth and
world champions kate threw punches and
worked with sprinters Oh while looking
fabulous and a green fitted top with
wide legged green pants and can we talk
about those sneakers with a touch of
glitter we stand
waiter in the day Kate congratulated the
crowd for the role they've played in
their children's success the mom of
three recently opened up about her
commitment to her own kids on the happy
mom happy baby podcast have an amazing
granny who devoted a lot of time for us
playing with our student during arts and
crafts and going to a green house doing
gardening stuff and cooking with us am I
trying incorporate a lot of the
experiences that she gave us at the time
into the experiences that I give my
children now between caring for her kids
and promoting her 5 big questions survey
but is not too late to have your say
Kate's been keeping busy but not too
busy for a date night on Tuesday Kate
stepped out with her hubby Prince
William in London's West End where they
attended a charity performance of dear
Evan Hansen
[Music]